- Sous pression. C'est le moment
de vérité pour les dirigeants
de Hockey Canada. L'ultime
cacasion de prouver qu'ils
sont les bonnes personnes pour
changer la culture du silence
dans leur organisation.
Des excuses pour la gestion
de l'affaire d'un viol collectif
à London, en Ontario, en 2018.
Des promesses de changer
la culture de l'organisation,
mais pas de démission.
Après un témoignage jugé opaque
le mois dernier, les dirigeants
de Hockey Canada tentent de
faire preuve de transparence.
Outre la compensation financière
pour la victime alléguée de
l'affaire de London, on apprend
que depuis 1989, Hockey Canada
pupuisé 7,6 millions de dollars
dans un fonds de réserve
pour conclure neuf ententes
à l'amiable avec des victimes
d'abus sexuels. Cela s'ajoee
à un montant de 1,3 million
payé par les assurances pour
12 affaires de nature sexuelle.
"Cet argent n'a pas servi à
protéger notre image, se défend
le PDG, mais bien  a appuyer
les victimes."
Or, des questions persistent
sur les actions des dirigeants.
Pourquoi avoir mis fin à
l'enquête sur le viol collectif
allégué de London en Ontario
après le versement d'une
compensation à la victime?
"Mettre fin à une enquête, est-
ce vraiment la façon d'opérer
un changement de culture?",
demande cette députée.
Scott Smith se défend d'avoir
voulu balayer l'affaire sous
le tapis.
Loin d'être convaincus
les députés de l'opposition
ont désavoué tour à tour
le grand patron de Hockey
Canada.
PETER JULIAN, député, NPD
- Ça prend un nouveau leadership
pour vraiment faire face
à cet échec total.
RICHARD MARTEL, député,
Parti conservateur du Canada
- Il est clair pour moi
que l'organisation a besoin
de redorer son blason et
de faire un grand ménage.
SÉBASTIEN LEMIRE, député, BQ
pour pouvoir mener à bien
les changemes s profonds
qu'on à faire dans l'ensemble de
la structure de Hockey Canada.
- Déçue du témoignage,
la ministre fédérale des Sport
exige aussi des changements
à la tête de Hockey Canada.
PASCALE ST-ONGE, ministre
fédérale des Sports
- Malgré la sincérité de
M. Smith, il semble y avoir
encore de la difficulté à
reconnaître les problèmes
systémiques au sein
de Hockey Canada.
- Le grand patron de Hockey
Canada n'a pas voulu prononcer
les mots crise et problèmes
systémiques lors de
son témoignage. Pas d'engagement
ferme non usus de faire
une meilleure place aux femmes
dans les sphères décisionnelles.